The following is a production of Frank Defratis and the Internet Web Zame of Holography.
Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk.
We actually have two guests this week.
We have Rob Taylor from Fourth Dimension Holographics in Nashville, Indiana.
And we have Mikhail Greetin.
I think that's how you pronounce the last name.
My apologies if it's pronounced incorrectly.
It's spelled G-R-I-C-H-I-N-E.
And Mikhail is the director of the Giola lab in Lithuania, and both will be on to tell us about the first totally automated holographic pulse camera system from Geola that's being installed here in the United States.
So we will have them on in just a minute.
But first, I have a few announcements to make.
First of which is happy birthday to my daughter, who's going to be twenty years old on November 2nd, and uh she is a physics and mathematics major whose professor was in one of my holography workshops back in the early 80s.
So I just want to say happy birthday to you and uh it is uh odd and strange feeling to finally have a daughter or child uh that's in their twenties now.
So what does that say about me?
She's the oldest of three, and happy birthday.
Got an email from TJ, Dr.
Jaeong from Lake Forest College, and he wanted to inform me that he now has a holography kit that he put together and is available for sale at his Integraph website, which is based around laser pointer or laser diode holography, and it comes uh with the laser diode, the film, the chemistry, and I believe one or two instruction manuals on how to do experiments using the kit.
So if you have an interest in purchasing the kit, you can go to the link page, and the link that you're looking for is Integraph.
Click on that link and it will take you to uh TJ's website and you can get more information and ordering information on this kit.
Also, I'd like to remind everyone that this Wednesday evening is the uh open house here in the studio at Allentown, Pennsylvania, and the topic is pulsed, not actually pulse, but the holographic portraits.
And it ties in very nicely with the uh show that we're having this week.
And when you come into the studio uh you'll be able to see examples of uh pulse holography and also uh a few holograms that were shot when myself and my youngest daughter went to New York to the uh Sony Center to have our holographic portraits done on Sony's instant stereographic holographic camera as well.
So we'll have them here.
And to close out the evening, we'll be showing you how you can do your own little holographic portraits using uh your typical uh equipment that you have in your studio, such as your sand table, your continuous wave helium neon or um uh diode laser system.
But what's interesting is you can shoot these holograms uh starting with your 35 millimeter camera, any standard 35 millimeter camera, and uh proceed to make your holographic portrait, and we'll take a look at both the holographic strip masters, the laser transmission masters, and also the transfers.
Now, of course, these holograms are nothing compared to the uh pulsed laser systems that are out there in some of the laboratories.
Uh but it makes very nice little holographic portraits that uh you could do on your own of your friends and family and pets or whatever, and uh you might want to come out and check that out.
It starts at 7 30 p.m.
promptly, runs about an hour and a half to nine o'clock.
It's uh free of charge, uh, but you do need to send me an email or give me a call on the phone to let me know to expect you to be here.
Uh there's refreshment served and we all have a pretty good time.
So let's move on to our interview and uh I just want to thank you for tuning in.
We're having a great season.
This is the third season here at Holo Talk and we're getting a lot of listeners this year.
Um each week I like to think that I'm able to bring you news and information concerning the fields of lasers and holography.
I hope you enjoy the show.
I try to have guests each week but occasionally I'll take a show on my own in case uh you know sometimes someone can't make it uh as scheduled or th just that there happens to be some information I'd like to pass along to you such as a special show that I have coming up on the reemergence of single beam holography which should be very interesting for a lot of amateurs and hobbyists out there to hear how you can do some very nice uh single beam holograms including uh image plane transfers and things of that nature that'll be coming up as well so I will say thank you for tuning in I'm not going to come on after the show's over and uh I hope you tune in each and every week to Holo Talk uh throughout this season which will run to Memorial Day in the year two thousand.
So thanks for tuning in.
Here's the show.
See you next week.
Well hello how did you know it was mecause uh this line doesn't get much use now we just uh activated this line for the studio.
Oh I see.
Well you're gonna have a lot of fun out there.
Yeah we sure are can't hardly stand it I'm so excited around right now.
Well why don't we start right off by you telling everyone what it is that you're doing out there.
Well, we have uh just installed and uh completed the first master and copying uh with the uh uh I guess you could say it's this hemisphere's first totally automated holographic pulse camera system.
And uh we uh have been installing it since last Thursday and uh today we just uh started doing the uh calibration and testing uh with uh test uh slavage plates and we just stuck the uh thirty by forty centimeter um H two transfer reflection copy on the drying rack about ten minutes ago.
Oh boy.
We did uh my I just recorded my father who's seventy two years old and he was my first test subject.
Well you know, I've always said that there's so many people in our history right now that really need to be recorded holographically.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
It's uh especially I I I see uh big uh applications for the very young and the very old, um, because you can record uh young uh children at the precious, you know, moment uh when they're you know at a certain age and they uh are really uh, you know, you always want to remember 'em a certain age and then uh, you know, ol older people that have uh developed uh, you know, have a lot of wisdom and uh that type of thing for uh you know, in the in their later years they have a lot of character built into their face.
It's uh it's a perfect time to record that person.
Yeah, very interesting three dimensional subjects.
Uh huh.
Yeah.
Yeah, and it's amazing for kids th who have had holographic portraits done that after five, ten, fifteen years have gone by and they go back and they look at themselves again, looking at themselves as kids.
Mm-hmm.
You know, staring back at themselves and that's that's an incredible feeling.
Yeah, it would be interesting to do, and I don't know that anybody's ever done it, but it would be interesting to do a child, um masters of a child through, you know, certain phases or ages of their life, uh and then um incorporate those masters in what to like say a three channel reflection hologram so that you could actually see 'em from a young age and then uh a little bit older, like say four or five years older and then say four or five years older later uh uh again.
That would be a interesting uh uh hologram.
That's a great idea.
Would it be too early for me to ask you the price of this service?
Um, no, uh-uh.
I think that we are going to be doing uh uh thirty by forty centimeter glass plate reflection copies for four hundred and ninety five dollars.
That's our targeted price, and I don't see any reason why uh through this uh just uh initial testing that we just completed that we can't stay on target with that price.
Mm-hmm.
That's very reasonable for yeah, that's uh pretty much a price breakthrough.
Yeah.
Now why don't you tell everybody where your studio's located and you also have a retail shop and everything there, don't you?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, we're in a little town uh in southern Indiana called Nashville, Indiana, where kind of in the heart of the Hoosier National Forest, um very uh picturesque and rustic area down here in uh southern Indiana.
Um it's uh uh kind of a tourist town with a lot of craftspeople that make their own uh products and so uh we like to think of ourselves as uh uh crafts people here too now that we're uh uh have this pulse telography system and we can be doing recording.
Is that a yes that's a solid state laser in that system, right?
Um yes, uhhuh.
Yeah.
It's uh uh neodymium Yelf uh glass phosphate laser.
Mm-hmm uh driven by a uh crystal.
I see.
Uh and flash lamps.
Actually we got the uh uh m most of the components uh last Thursday and uh unfortunately through the shipping uh from uh Lithuania we uh experienced one flash lamp that had broken and in the uh main amplifier.
So we have been waiting for about oh two or three days to get that in and we just got that in last night at five o'clock so we installed that last night and uh we're up and running this morning.
What's the uh power requirements?
Um we're using two hundred and twenty or two hundred and forty volts but uh i it's uh single phase and you can you could you can power this thing actually over a standard one ten current.
No kidding.
Yes.
Wow.
Yeah it's uh it's a pretty uh exciting thing to be involved in.
I'm I'm very very excited and lucky to be able to have this.
Is that relatively new this technology or has it been around for many years?
Um well industry applied to the system.
It's uh it's a relatively new technology I would think.
Uh you know I um I I would probably like to refer you to uh Mikhail because he's uh actually the inventor of the camera system or most of the components within um he uh works with Geola, uh the company that uh actually manufactures this camera system in Lithuania.
Mm-hmm.
We uh um actually formed a partnership to get this into the United States and uh used components both from the US and uh Lithuania and Russian based technology.
Uh so we uh kind of formed a combination to actually uh get the re required parts together and actually assemble a camera system here.
How easy is it to get to your shop from any or could you name some of the larger metropolitan areas that are around you.
Yeah we're about um uh hour south of Indianapolis which is the capital of Indiana.
Um Cincinnati, uh Col um Columbus, Chicago, uh Louisville, Kentucky, all those are within easily driving distance of you know, say one to two hours.
Oh really?
Yeah.
We're we're kind of um centrally located in between those areas.
And I would imagine for a pulse portrait something that special that it wouldn't be beyond anyone to make a day trip and overnight trip out of it.
No, no stay somewhere and have that done during the day, sight C and that's our feeling because it we we plan on making this a a same day service even uh uh with this totally being a totally automated system we've uh uh we can go from mastering to copying mode um real you know basically with a flick of a switch in about less than thirty seconds.
So my goodness um we plan on you know doing sittings in the morning and then uh people can shop within the two hundred plus little shops within Nashville and have a nice meal or something, come back view their master and then we'll process the copy out and dry it and should have the uh reflection copy by you know uh that evening.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, you say you have Mikhail okay.
Um yeah, he's here and uh he can uh tell you more about this uh camera system and the technology behind it.
Uh I'm going to have a link up to your website for the show.
I don't know your phone number.
Great.
And um like I said, I'm I'm really excited.
I'll let you talk to him.
I'm gonna go and see if my dad's plate is dry and I can't first reflection copy.
I know that feeling.
Hey, nice talking to you, Frank.
Okay.
Hello.
Mikhail, how are you?
Uh uh okay.
This is Frank DeFratis.
Uh yeah.
We do a radio show here called Hole Talk.
Uh yeah, yeah, I know.
Yeah, you know.
Okay.
I have a couple of questions I'd like to ask you.
Uh uh and first off maybe we should uh just take a few minutes to speak about Geola.
If you could tell us a little bit about the company.
Uh yeah.
Um Giolo was formed in um uh nineteen ninety-four uh as a sister company of Australian holographics.
Um Australian holographics it was uh it's pretty well known company in uh field of uh watch holography.
Mm-hmm.
It's located in um Adelaide, South Australia.
And this car company is specialized in uh large format display holography.
I see.
Using tradition traditional lasers at the uh you're u uh using um yeah continuous earth lasers.
Yeah.
And those houses uh for for holograms were really exciting.
It was up to one by two meters rainbow holograms and up to one by one meter reflection.
Oh, that they're pretty big reflection home, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I don't even think I've uh ever s well maybe I have.
Did they ever have any work that was in images and time and space or any of those other exhibits that went around, you know?
Uh you know, really I don't know exactly.
I know there's a lot of uh the um uh holograms were exhibited in um in Asia, in uh in country like Malaysia, mm Taiwan, Singapore I think.
I see.
Yeah, um most the market was uh what products and services do you currently offer to the field of philography with Geola?
Uh maybe uh just add a couple of words about uh uh our further uh uh mm you know uh growing of our company and they'll tell about our product which is uh which we have now.
Okay.
I think uh so that they can go to the website.
Uhhuh.
On on the web page.
Yeah.
Uh uh our uh uh sorry, it's uh question about uh do we have uh our website or I'll I'll put a link uh to your website so people can go there and see about Geola.
Uh uhhuh, yeah.com.
Yeah.
What about the uh holographic portrait system?
Can you tell us a little bit about that and its operation?
About uh our uh portrait, the holographic uh camera.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Okay, so let's uh uh I'll begin maybe a little from history.
Because uh uh this uh technique actually uh was uh started in um in our company in uh nineteen ninety six, in the middle of nineteen ninety six and uh Geola carried out some research work in order to record uh final holograms by copies with uh solid state pulse laser.
And um first experiments were pretty successful and uh the same time new to f uh technology of um uh color control for reflection hologram was introduced and so th those two things actually were basis of our uh future uh uh design and uh then we exhibited high quality reflection holograms uh uh forty by sixty centimeters uh printed with this uh technique a completely pulse technique in uh laser ninety seven trade fair in Munich and then one month later we uh exhibited them in uh the international symposium for display holography uh in uh Lake Forest in the UC.
And uh since that after that time jail actually become separate from us with uh from Australian holographic and uh our company with mostly with the most uh advanced pulse technology for display holography.
Uh as uh regarding our um uh present um product oh uh our traditional field of activity i i is uh uh high uh large format holography and uh pulse lasers for this and uh so we offer a range of uh high energy lasers based on neodymium yield neodymium phosphate glass system and recently we completed design of range of laser for general scientific applications.
Mm-hmm.
Uh of course we produce uh holograms itself, so currently it's up to one by one meter size.
Uh both reflection and rainbows.
What's the uh largest size that the camera will produce?
Um this camera can produce uh sixty by forty and actually it's uh our uh standard size.
Yeah that's nice.
But there is no restriction in uh laser energy.
Uh no I mean at least for say sixty by eight centimeters uh it's possible to uh to build such a camera.
Yeah.
And uh yeah is this the first unit in the United States?
Yeah, that's true.
In the United States that's the first.
That's the first.
What about the Slavic recording materials?
Now y you're a distributor for those, right?
Or yeah yeah, mm-hmm.
Now it's uh pretty uh well known m materials on the wall in holography community.
And uh you know after art for discontinued production of holographic materials, uh this emotion from Slavage uh slowly but surely occupies this market.
Mm-hmm.
And uh hello plates uh PG zero one it's actually they have uh three families of of uh materials.
It's um uh uh fine grain, ultra fine grain and decromated gelatin.
So P G01 and P G and VIP M.
Uh uh fine grained material for mm P G zero one for red uh recording and uh p uh the P V M is uh uh green sensitive material.
Yeah.
And uh and the O one it works fine for reflection holography as well, doesn't it?
Yeah, both.
Both.
Both yeah.
And they're pretty similar to to ECFAS, uh uh respectively uh H E seventy five H D and H E fifty six H D.
Yeah.
The O one is, not the O three.
Uh uh Zero one.
Yeah.
Zero three is uh ultra fine grain.
It's a next uh family.
And next family is uh PG03M and G03C.
Both are ultra fan grain material.
Oh, I see.
They have slightly less sensitivity.
Um PG03M is red sensitive and PG03C is uh with uh panchromatic response.
Do both do both the zero one and the zero three require late tensification in the process or just um not really, not really.
Um you know, with identification I can explain.
Um actually um pulse work requires.
If uh you know one records uh just uh with a continuous with hologram, uh it's not necessary to use latencification at all.
Okay.
Yeah, usually of course they use uh low power uh hean lasers.
Yeah, some of these guys, you know, have these labs in their house.
Yeah.
Uh with five milliwatt, ten milliwatt uh HANA lasers and they're shooting four by five inch uh plates or foam and they're wondering, you know, do they have to do this late densification or not necessarily at all, not necessary.
Uh the um late densification brings the uh sensitivity of uh holographic plates uh uh uh in pulse, which is usually less, maybe several times less than um sensitivity for uh continuous wave radiation.
So this process brings uh this uh uh sensitivity approximately to the same level.
Yes that equalizer.
Mm-hmm.
And that is why it's uh really useful for uh uh pulse work.
Any other information you can give us about the camera?
Do you expect to have any more installations here in the uh states?
Um now we are building uh camera for Germany for some medical application.
Mm-hmm.
I don't know exactly it's some uh phase surgery and um and we have uh several other possible uh contracts.
But it's you know, it's still uh I mean it's uh still in progress and so I cannot uh give more details about this.
Would it be okay if I asked you what the price of one of these systems runs?
If someone wanted to contact you to get one of these systems, what's the price of one of these systems?
Well actually it depends on uh uh you know, on uh final requirements, uh size, uh and uh but actually it's somewhere around uh hundred thousand.
Hundred thousand dollars.
Yeah.
It's uh really serious technique and uh quite complicated uh, you know, machine and uh you know it can not be too cheap.
Yeah, yeah.
And what's what's the lifetime on the uh on the laser usually uh as long as the flash lamp lasts I would imagine.
I mean does the rod excel itself have to ever be replaced or just the flash there.
Uh no for flash lamp you usually f uh in our system f uh masterful like the flash lamp requires uh replacement maybe once a year and the in uh the amplifier uh we never replaced uh flash lamp in our amplifiers.
I uh it's I suppose uh they really last for forever.
Then it requires some maintenance maybe once a two months, you know, one can clean some optics inside and stuff like that.
Mm.
Doesn't run off of batteries either does it.
Uh just a joke.
We've been working with a lot of these little diodes that we can use little batteries on, so this is a whole nother ball game for everybody that's doing all the things that we're gonna do.
Yeah and but I I think it maybe in I don't know, maybe in ten years time uh similar to ours uh system you know we fit it into the size of I don't know maybe a fax machine or something.
Yeah I bet it sounds like a wonderful system.
Just the way that it is right now.
It sounds like a wonderful system.
I mean it's it seems awful simple just to go from an H one to an H two copy, you know, just Yeah yeah that's really just uh issue of pressing of one button and that's it it's done.
Yeah normally that would take quite a bit of time to reset up a holography table to uh make the transfer.
Yeah of course of course you know the m major uh I think um feature of the system is uh that we use the same laser for mastering and for copying.
Because first it's uh it costs less.
Yeah.
And second we have the same wavelength for recording and then for image planning.
Mm-hmm.
And uh third that we use pulse laser for both.
Yeah.
And uh you imagine the uh vibration is isolation uh requirements for uh especially for large format holography.
That's really severe problem, you know.
If you go for formats larger than I don't know, thirty by forty it becomes yeah really complicated.
So those you know, all those techniques they actually work well.
Anything else you'd like to add to the show before we close it out I don't know.
Anyone you'd like to say hello to?
Ah yeah to Sergei Varabyev.
He's uh uh friend, he's holographer uh from Moscow and by the way this is his um invention uh not really invention but he found this uh trick with uh classification for uh the APM material.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah what else and maybe uh I would say uh hello to uh Yuri Susanov he's a director of m micron Plum.
Actually he's a producer of uh photographic materials and he's a good friend of mine.
Okay.
So Yeah, everybody can listen to this show because it's on the internet.
Yeah.
Alright, well thank you very much, Mikhail, for uh coming on the show and telling us about the new laser system.
Hi, you're welcome.
Tell Rob I said thank you and good luck with everything and thank you.
I'm sure everybody will be interested in going to your website for Geola and also uh Rob's uh website.
Yeah, thank you for your interest.
Okay.
Take care.
Thank you.